サッバパパスアカラナン クサラッサウペサンパーダ サチッタパリヨーダパナング エータンブッダンササーサナン
[鐘の音] 南無タスゥ バガトー アラーハトォ サンマーサムダスィ
南無タスゥ バガトー アラーハトォ サンマーサムナスィ
南無タスゥ バガトー アラーハトォ サンマサンブンデスィ
仏陀ム シャラナム ガチャミ
仏ダームシャラナップ ガッチャーニ
ダンマン シャラナン ガッチャーミー
シャンガン シャラナーン ガッチャーミー
サンガーン シャラナン ガッチャーミー
デュティアンピ ブッダム シャラナン ガッチャーミー
デュティヤン ピ ブッダメ スラン ガッシャーニー
デュティ ヤン プー ダルマン シュラ ナン ガッチャー ミー
デュティアもピー ダン マンス ラン なんかっちゃ うみ
デュティー アンキー サンガン シャラнам ガッチャー ニ
デュティ ヤンプ リ さん がんさら なんだっつぁ に
タテ やんきい ブッダ ム シェリ ナン カッちゃん に
タティ ヤン キーブ ドゥッド ウイン サラ マンガチャ
カティ ヤンキ ダン マルン ショール ナン ガッチャー ミー
ハティ ヤン ピ ダン マンス ララ намゴー カッチャー ミー
タティ ヤンビ サンガン シャラナム ガッチャー ニ
ハティ ヤンピッ サンガン サラナン ゴッカ
アーナーディ パーター ウェーラ マニ シッカー パダン サマーディーヤーミー
バーナー ティーパー タ ーラ マニ シカー パドン サマー ディやー み
アドイレダーナー ベーラ マニ シーカー パダン サマーディア メ
アダ インナー ハーナー ウィーラ マニ シッカー パダン サマート ディヤーミー
カーネシュニン チャイチェ レベリング マニ シッター パダン サマー 디야 あみ
あメース ミッチャン チェーラー ウェーラ マニ シッカー パダン サマーディヤー ミー
モッサージ でウェーラ マニ シッカー パダン サマー ディヤー ミー
ムー沢だ わべら まにい しかぱ談 サマー ディヤー ミー
sura メロよ まじょとまあだったな
ヴェーラ マニ シッカー パダン サマーディ アーメン
スラ веレイ亜麻ジャパマジック だからなぁ
ヴェーラ マニ シッカー パダン サマー ディヤー ミ 【
鐘の音】 懺悔誓願黙読
懺悔致します 無明の闇におおわれて
身口意の三業によって犯してしまった過ちがあります
佛法僧に対する過ち 恩師に対する過ち
生きとし生けるものに対する過ち
これは一切の過ちを懺悔いたします
また 自分が受けた他の人々の過ちも赦します
このように雑事を離れ
一人静かに自己的身心を念をもって見つめる時
瞬間瞬間変化消滅し続ける現象をヴィパッサナーによって洞察し
真の幸福を得て解脱の道へ導かれますようにと
ここに誓願をいたします 【
鐘の音】 なお多数爆発後へと参謀さん分ダンス 名も立つバラトゥワあとさまあさんぶんだんす
...ナモー タンスー バガトー アリヤトー サッマー サム ブッダンセー イティ ピソー バガワーラ サッマー
サム ブッドー ヴィンヤー チャラーナ サンパンナ スガトー ローカインドゥ アナンターロー プーリサ
ダンマ サーラティ サッターデーヴァ マヌッサナ ブンドー バンガーティー
ブッダン ジータ パリヤンタン サラナン ガンチャーミー
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
サカートー バガター ダンモ サンディンティーコーカーリーコー エーパッシーコー オーパナイーコー パンチャンタン ヴェーディタ
ンモ ヴィンユー イティ
ダンマン ジータ パリヤンタン サラナン ガンチャーミー
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
スパティパンノー バガヴァトーサーヴァカ サンゴー ウジュ パティパンノー バガヴァトーサーヴァカ サンゴー ニャーヤ
パティパンノー バガヴァトーサーヴァカ サンゴー サミーチ パティパンノー バガヴァトーサーヴァカ サンゴー
ヤディ ガンチャンターリ プーリサ ユガーニ アンタ プーリサ プンガラー エーサ バガヴァトーサーヴァカ サンゴー
アーフネイヨ パーフネイヨ ダンキネイヨ アンジャリ カーラニヨ
アナンタラン プンヤン キンタン ローカン サティ
サンガム ジータ パリヤンタン サラナン ガンチャーミー
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
カーヤナ ワージャ チントン パマーデーナ マヤーカタン アンジャヤン カマメ バンテ ドゥーリ パンニャ タターガタ
カーヤナ ワージャ チンテーナ パマーデーナ クーヤーカタン アンジャヤン カマメ ダンナ サンディンティーカーカーリータ
カーヤナ ワージャ チントン パ...ナーンデーナマヤカタアンジャヤンカマメサンガシュパティパンナアヌンタラー
サササ はい それでは仏陀菩薩をお願いします
ナモタッサバーガトアーラハトサッマサンブッダッス
ガンサランパディッテーナディーペーナタマダンシナ
トリローカディーパサンブッダンプージャヤーミタモヌダン
暗黒を破るこの明かりで
三世界の暗闇を破る灯明である釈迦牟尼如来を礼し奉る
ワンナガンダグノーペタンエタンクスマサンタティン
プージャヤーミムニンダンサシーリーパーダサロールエ
彩色芳香により麗しき数多の御花で
サティムニ如来の御足を礼し奉る
プージェーミブッダンクスメーナネーナ
プンニエーナメーテーナラバーミモッガン
ウッパンニラーヤーティヤターイランメーカーヨータターヤーティヴィナーサバワン
我は 我はこの花をもって大聖所大聖ブッダをね
礼し奉らん  この功徳によって解脱が得られんことを
必ずしおれかれるこの身の如く
我が肉体もまた滅び行くものなり
シュガンダーディカーヤワダナンアナンタグナガンダナシュガンダナンガンダナプージャヤーミアターガタン
その御言葉は 香りの化粧の如く
無量の徳の香りをまといし
釈迦牟尼如来をこの香をもって礼し奉る
シュガンダイカシュガンダンシータランカンパンパサンナマドゥランシュガン
パニヤメタンバガパティガンナトゥナヤコ
透明にして清らかなる
また生きに敵に敵わないし
この飲み水を釈迦牟尼如来に献上し
奉る世尊がお受け取りなされますように
アディワセトゥノーバンテボージャナンパリカンピタン
アヌカンパンルパダヤパティガンナトゥムンタマン
偉大なる釈迦牟尼如来よ
我ら調理せし この御食を憐れみをもって受け取らんことを願い奉る
アディワセトゥノーバンテサンバンサンダーヤプーリタン
アヌカンパンルパダヤパティガンナトゥムンタマン
偉大なる釈迦牟尼如来よ
我ら用意せし そのその他の供物も
憐れみをもって受け取らんことを願い奉る
ニヴェーダヤーニサンブッダン・ヴィータラーガンマムニン
ニマンタヤーニシュガタン・ローカジェンタンナラサマン
少学者 煩悩の滅尽者 大聖者に食事の時を授け奉る
先生 世間上衆 衆生人を接待し奉る
カーヤナワーチャ・チンターナ・アマゲーナマヤカタン
アッチャヤン・カマメバンテ・ブーリパンニャ・タターガタ
大医者たる如来に対して
己が怠りにより犯した身語意の過ちを懺悔いたします
はい カーヤナワーチャチンターナパマーデーナマヤーカタン
パッチャヤンカマメダンマサンディンティカアカーリカ
実証できる永遠の真理たる仏法に対して
己が怠りにより犯した身語意の過ちを懺悔いたします
カーヤナワーチャチンターナパマーデーナマヤーカタン
パッチャヤンカマメサンガスパティパンニャーアヌンターラ
無常なる聖道を実践せる僧団に対して
己が怠りにより犯した身語意の過ちを懺悔いたします
サード サード サード ［鐘の音］サッブパーパッサアカルナームクシャランサウパサンタダー
サチンタパリヨーダパナム
エタンブッダナサーサナム
カンタパーマタポーティティンカー
ニッバーナムパーマムワダンティブッダ
ナエパッバジェトパールーパガティシャマノーティパラムヴィアタヤントゥ
アヌパワドーアヌパガトーパーティモンクエチャサンワロー
マッタンユターチャバンダスミーンパンタンチャサヤナーサナム
アディチンタチャーヨーガエタンブッダナサーサナム
［鐘の音］それでは慈悲の瞑想いたします
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の願いごとが叶えられますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
私は幸せでありますように
私は幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じます
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
私の親しい生命の悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
私の親しい生命の願いごとが叶えられますように
私の親しい生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
私の親しい生命が幸せでありますように
これから親しい生命が幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じます
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
生きとし生けるものの悩み苦しみがなくなりますように
生きとし生けるものの願いごとが叶えられますように
生きとし生けるものにも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
これから生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにと繰り返し念じます
[音楽]私の嫌いな生命が幸せでありますように
私の嫌いな生命の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私の嫌いな生命の願い事が叶えられますように
私の嫌いな生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
私を嫌っている生命が幸せでありますように
私を嫌っている生命の悩み
苦しみがなくなりますように
私を嫌っている生命の願い事が叶えられますように
私を嫌っている生命にも悟りの光が現れますように
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
では 回向のところにいきます
エッターターチャメーサンバタンプンヤサンパダンサンベーデーヴァアヌモーダンとサンダサンタンティシンディーア
ここまで我々が積みししたすべての功徳なる祭砲を
神々が推挙してお受けくださいますように
あまねくすべての神々が福徳に満たされますように
エッターヴァターチャアンメサンバタンプンヤサンパダンサンベーブータアヌモーダン
サンバサンパッティシンディア
ここまで我々が済みしたすべての功徳なる祭砲を
聖霊が推挙してお受けくださいますように
あまねくすべての精霊が福徳に満たされますように
エッターターキャンデーサンバタンポニャサンパダンサンデーサンターナモダントゥサンバサンパッティシンディア
ここまで我々が済みしたすべての功徳なる祭砲を
一切の衆生が推挙してお受けくださいますように
あまねく一切の衆生が福徳に満たされますように
はい これから戦卒用の偈です
イダンメーニャーティナンオトゥスキターオントゥニャータヨイダンメーニャーティナンオトゥスキターオントゥニャータヨイダンメーニャーティナンオトゥスキターオントゥニャータヨ
この功徳が戦争に届きますように
戦争が安らぎに満たされますように
誓願 イダンメーポニャンアーサワンカヤーワンオトゥイダンメーポニャンアーサワンカヤーワンオトゥイダンメーポニャンアーサワンカヤーワンオトゥ
この功徳により 我々は涅槃へ導かれんことを
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
はい それでは すべての生命の中で現れる唯一の偉大なる方であるお釈迦様の降誕と成仏と涅槃を祝うウェーサーカ祭りの日で
我々は色々事情があって
とても殊勝な形で心込めてお釈迦様に礼拝をいたしました
お釈迦様のお布施を食事のお布施をいたしました
この功徳とお釈迦様の釈迦牟尼仏陀の無量の偉大なる功徳の力によって
この法要に参加した皆様方に
皆様方のご家族のご家族の皆様方に
ご親戚 友人たち 皆様方に
それからこの世界のすべての生命に幸福がありますように
安らぎが訪れますように
安穏に過ごせけますように
心清らかになりますように
涅槃に解脱に達することができますようにと誓願いたします
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
はい 終わりです ではサンケーと御回向になります
Namotass
a bhagavato arahato sammasambuddhassa namotassa bhag
avato arahanto sammasambuddhassa
namotassa bhagavato arahato sammasambuddhassa サーンケイ私の後で唱えてください
ブッダんさらなーんガチャーミー
ダンサランガッチャミ
ダンマンサラナン ガッチャーミ
ダンマントラガンチャ
サンガンサラダン ガンチャーミ
サンガンガチャミ  デュティアピ ブッドン サルナァン ガンチャン ミィ
ティアンピー ブッダメ
サラム ガッカチ  デュティーヤン ピ ダンマン サル ナン ガン チャーミ
ピッタン マンスラナム カッコウ
デュティー ヤンピー サンガン サラン ガン チャーム
ビッキー サンガン スラム гаッチャミ
パティ アンプ ビップ ダм シャラー ナン ガン チャールミ
アンプ プッダム サラン ガッツ
タティ アンティ ダン マンシャラン ガン チャーム
サンガム サラング ガッチャミ
タティ アンディ サンガン サラнам ガッチャミ
サンガム サラカム ガッチャニ
パーナーティ パータウェーブ ウェーラ マニー シッカー Padam サマーディーヤーミ
バーナー ティーパーター веロ マニー シッカーPadam サマーディア
アドリンナードーナーヴェーラ マニーシカー Padan サマーディーヤーミ
アリンダ パーラウェイ ラマニス ディーカー padang サマーディア ミ
カメスミンシャーチャラーヴェーラ マニー シッカー Padan サマーディーヤーミ
アーメン スミッ chara ヴェーラ マニー シッカーpadang サマディア
ムーザーワーダーヴェーラ マニー シッカーPadan サマーディーヤーミ
ムーサル ワーズ デーヴァ尼僧 Kakka padang サマディア ミ
シュラーメーレイ マッジャパ マーダン タナヴェーラ マニー シッカー padan サマダイヤ ミー
スーラー メライ マツヤマ ダッターナデーラ マニー シッカー 파당 사마디 아미
懺悔誓願ども  懺悔致します
無明の闇におおわれて
身口意の三宝によって犯してしまった過ちがあります
仏法僧に対する過ち 父母師に対する過ち
生きとし生けるものに対する過ち
これらの一切の過ちを懺悔いたします
また 自分が受けた他の人々の過ちも赦します
このように雑事を離れ
一人静かに自己的心身を念を持って見つめる時
瞬間瞬間変化消滅し続ける現象をヴィパッサナーによって洞察し
心の幸福を得て解脫の道へ導かれますようにとここに誓願を出します
nama 미 부던 군에 샤갈랑탕サンタサダーオントリースキー阿弥陀花
...よじぐんちょ さかろ度願どがんちゃんて
サンデマナナーンシャ
ナマミダンナンシュガテーナデシタ
サンタサダオンとスキーアヴィーラ
カーヨジグンチョーサカロドゥガンドーガンシャンティサンデマナナンアンチョ
ナマミサンガンムニラジャサワカンサンタサダオンとスキーアヴィーラ
サードサードサード はい
それではウェーサーカ法要のねぶをこれから行います
あのお釈迦様のお祝いを
まあみんないろいろ形でずっと昔から行ってきましたが
で ちょっと他の人の誕生日のお祝いと違うところは
大きい違うところがあるんです
我々は人にお誕生日おめでとうございますって人に祝福するんですね
お釈迦様の場合は お釈迦様のお誕生日おめでとうございますって言わないんです
で そう言ってはならないんです
だからお釈迦様の降誕だけではなく
成仏 涅槃も 3つの出来事を一つにして
ウェーサーカ式典を行うようにしているんです
で なぜ祝福しないのかというと
お釈迦様のことを念じて
お釈迦様の言葉を聞いて
あるいはお釈迦様の教えたものを一部でも実践して
我々は祝福いただくんです
幸福をいただくんです
だから俗世間の誕生パーティーとは違うところなんです
だから私たちは一人一人の祝福のために
幸福のために 安穏のために
功徳を積むために 心を清らかにする目的を
自分の幸福を目指して
お釈迦様のこの祭壇 最最大の出来事を見つを祝います
はい で 毎年私は説明しますが
あっ 忘れたポイントがありまして
ウェーサーカ法要のやり方は2つあります 1
つはもう俗世間的にこの派手に祭りやることなんです
で これは世の中で一般的に俗世間にも祭りがあるし
宗教世界といえばもう祭りしか何もないし
時々祭りが宗教の管轄を飛んで
みんな祭りだけやる場合もありますね
例えばクリスマスというのは日本中お祝うんですね
日本人がキリスト教といったらもうほとんどほとんどない
教会にちょっと日曜日顔を入れてみたら
まあ年取った５ ６人しかいない
宗教に興味ないんです
しかし クリスマスになってくると
だいたい 10月から始まるんですね
だからそれはキリスト教の一つのお祭りが宗教範囲を飛ばしちゃって
世界的に広がったということになっているんです
だからどんな宗教にも祭りがありますから
仏教の人々ももうこれ楽ちんだと思って派手にお祭りすることになったんですね
だからウェーサーカ祭りっていうのは
他の国のこと私はよくわかりませんだけど
自分の国だったら国全体的にお祭りをするんです
お祭りに参加しない人はいない
どれほど強烈かというと
まあキリスト教の方々もずるずると参加する
もう逃げられなくなっちゃうんですね
無理やりに参加させちゃうんです
宗教を信仰的に押し付けないんだから
みんな気持ちよくお祭りに参加して
楽しく遊んで終わっちゃうんですね
これが2日間続くんです
時々 1週間やる場合もあります
お釈迦様は涅槃に入りますよと
いわゆる亡くなりますよと宣言して宣伝して
最後の 3ヶ月ですね 世界みんな知っていたんで
お釈迦様がもうこの 3ヶ月終わったところで涅槃亡くなりますと
そこでみんなお釈迦様に挨拶しに来る
で もう次から次 次から次と人が来るわ来るわ来るわ来る終わりがないんです
で お釈迦様は最後に住むために
最後の時期のために選んだと
町はヴェーサーリという国で
あの だいたい民主主義的な国で
お釈迦様の気に入る国でもありましたし
ほとんど90%ぐらいというか
ほとんど仏教の人々で仏教になったのは
ウェーサーリ国の政治家たちがみんなもう仏教徒になったからなんですね
だからお釈迦様が住んでいる場合は
だいたいあの この国の行事やってる議事堂
大きい丸い建物がありまして
そちらにお釈迦様が住むんです
だからお釈迦様が 3ヶ月間いるならば
この国会活動はすべてやめるんです
国の活動はやめて みんなお釈迦様を中心にしてお釈迦様のお世話することに国全体的になるんです
で それで政治的な問題は一切ないんです
誰も喧嘩もしないし 強盗もしないし
犯罪もないし だからもうすごい楽ちんということになるんですね
また お釈迦様とお坊さんたちはもう国会で寝泊まりしているんだったらね
もう議員さんたちには何もできないでしょうね
で それは何のことなかったんですね
当時は お釈迦様は最後にも涅槃に入れた時も
その同じ国でになりましたし
で 最後は国会には行かなかったんですね
もうずっと旅をして このポワッタナという名前の公園で涅槃に入られましたけどね
だからずっと人々はもう次から次へ来る
でもお釈迦様がもう80歳で
あの赤痢という病気にかかってきて
もう体はもたないんですね
体力がないんです それでも精神的な力でずっと頑張って
みんなにみんなに何かや何か一言葉説法したりしたり
ずっといて どんどん見るとお釈迦様に対して
この 俗世間的な態度はちょっと大きくなってくるんですね
要するにお釈迦様にいろんなお供え物は持ってくるわ
だから食事は 1 日 1回だけだからね
それは何とかなるんだけど
いろんな供養物を持ってきて
もうみんなもう必死でもう最後だ
最後だ 力ということで
お花やらあれやこれやとか
その時初めて人間にこの天界の花も見ることはできたんだと
天界のこの下の次元と上の次元
三次元ぐらいの神々なんですけど
そちらに咲く花まで持ってきて
お釈迦様のところに置いておくんですね
だから花だらけになるんですね
でお坊さんたちはそれを片付けなくちゃいけない
だからみんな一言葉喋りたいし
ご挨拶をしたいし 何か供養ものを差し上げたいし
っていうか 供物でたってもお花程度になっちゃうしね
またいろんなところでいろいろ灯りをつけてあげたりとかね
お釈迦様はそれを見て
こんなことで如来を尊敬したことになるのかい？と
お釈迦様が考えているのは
悟りに達してお釈迦様の唯一仕事は真理を人々に教えることなんですね
真理っていうのは頭で理解することはできないんですね
実践しなくちゃいけないんですね
だから実践的な教えですから
心の汚れを落としなさいなんですね
だから人は心の汚れを落とすことをしないんだったら
お釈迦様の話は全部水の泡になるんです
お釈迦様はすごいすごいすごいと言ったっても
何かお釈迦様にとっては何だこれはと
あんた方に別にすごいと言われたくても
言われなくても 痛くも痒くも何でもないんだという態度なんです
神々が来て お釈迦様にも会うことができて
本当にありがとう お釈迦様とうるさいだけなんですね
だから お釈迦様がおっしゃったのは
最後の言葉に入っているのは
こういうこの俗世間的なお祭り
もののお布施などなどにはよりは
ほんのちょっとの時間でも
私が言っていることをやってみるならば
それこそ本物のブッダを賛嘆したことになるんだよと
だから人は実践するならば
その実践そのものがお釈迦様を賛嘆することになるんです
だから その方がものすごい幸福になるし
幸せになるし 功徳にもなります
だからお釈迦様のことを大事に思うならば
我々に唯一できることは自分で教えをやる
ことなんです 自分で牛をやってみると
いつでもお釈迦様の祝福は体で感じられるようになります
あ なんかすごい力で守られているんだと
何の不幸も来ないんだと
で 経験的にわかることはできるんです
お釈迦様は助けてください
お釈迦様 私を守ってくださいと言っても全然効き目がないんです
言葉空になってしまうんです
それではなくて お釈迦様はこういうふうにおっしゃったんだから
じゃあやってみますと
やってみる人のところで
お釈迦様の仏像がなくても
仏壇がなくても あれ なんか守られてるんだと
いろいろなところで 本当に何の危険もなく
危険なところがあっても
自分が守られているんだということをよく感じられるようになるんです
だから この実践している人々にとってはお釈迦様っていうのはもういつでも自分と一緒にいる存在なんです
もう全くもう影もない
もうまるっきり全く妄想観念だけの話じゃないんです
昔の人の話だよということではなく
いつでも自分のそばにいるすごい偉大なる存在っていう感じがするんですね
だから そういう法則があります
でお釈迦様はそれは最後にも教えましたからね
実践しなさいと それこそブッダに対する尊敬であり
挨拶であり 礼拝であり
讃嘆であるんだと ですから基本的に仏教賛美歌なんかはある必要
作る必要はないんだけど
まあスリランカで一般人が歌を歌う歌うリストの中で
まあ 6割  7割ぐらい仏教の歌ばっかりなんです
だからどんな歌手でも
一曲  2つ  3つぐらいでも仏教の内容を歌わないと
なかなか立場がないんです
歌手がキリスト教であろうか
イスラム教であろうと関係ないんです
とにかく仏教の歌も必ず歌うという風になってしまったんですね
しかし それはブッダの本心ではありません
やることなんですね やってみることです
で 今日ちょっと思い浮かんだことではなくて
ちょっと今日経典一つ二つを開けてみたんだけど
その時ちょっと目に入った場所が 1箇所があって
これたとえ話で ある人が朝
車 100台 財産をいっぱいに持ってきて寄付をする
昼もまた 100台の車
車っていうのは大きい牛車とか
まあ現代的なトラックだと思ってください
まあ中型程度のトラックとかね
もうじゃあトラックにします
トラック 100台 昼も財産いっぱい積んでまた寄付をする
午後もまた 100台 トラック 100台
財産 あらゆる財産いっぱい積んで
また人々に寄付をすると
すごいことでしょうと
普段個人にはできるものでもないんです
しかし あの牛の 雌牛のあのおっぱいやりますね
おっぱいから乳搾るでしょ
今は機械ですけど 昔は手で搾るんですね
誰かが牛のおっぱいから一回乳を搾るぐらいの時間
要するにまあ 5秒  6 秒ぐらい
まあ長くて 10 秒にしましょうか
まあチェックしてないんです
まあうち乳搾りは見たことがあるんだけどね
時々私の姉もこれやっていてのは見たことはあるんだけど
姉には聞き忘れちゃった
一回搾るためにどれくらい時間がかかるのかと
で 10 秒ぐらいにしましょう
だから牛のおっぱいで一回ちりっと乳を搾るぐらいの時間
慈悲の気持ちを育ててれば
あの人がやってる徳とかなわないぐらい徳が積めますよと
比較するなよと そこでこのたとえ話のおかげで
我々にはこの思考不可能な世界を理解できます
トラック一台ものすごい財産いっぱいにするということは
我々にとっては えっ できるわけ
そんな金があるわけないでしょうにと
もうこれ円で言えば分かりやすいね
例えばトラック一台 すごい財産いっぱいにするためには
例えばもう 1,000万ぐらいの価値があると
これ朝も昼も夜も個人に 3,000万あるわけないんですね
でも 10秒ぐらい慈悲の瞑想をすれば
それと比較にならないぐらい得になりますよと
で もう一つ例えがありまして
その例で使う植物の名前はちょっと日本語でもわからないし
インドのものだから私もよくピンとこないんです
触ったらすごい怪我する硬いものなんですね
あの だからそれを手で絞ること
絞ってもう潰すことはできるのかと
一切できませんと 手が怪我するだけやと
その例を使って ほんの瞬間でも慈悲の瞑想をする人は
潰すことは誰にもできませんと
だから慈悲の気持ちある人
では 日本語を日本文化に入れ替えようと思ったら
思い浮かんだのは栗なんですね
だから 木から栗を手で取って
手で開けて 全部手でやろうと思ったらできるんですかね
手袋も使わないで怪我するだけなんですね
例えば綺麗に開けている栗でも
手で触っちゃうと危なくて
もうしょうがないんですね
だから慈悲がしない世界は
慈悲を実践しない世界は
いくら凶暴であっても
慈悲の気持ちある人にとっては何のすることもできないんだと
そこで前のネット中継
誰かがこの幽霊の話 悪霊の話も聞いていたんだけど
それに似ているプレースもあって
例えば悪霊たちが一生懸命誰かに悪いことをしようと
いくら頑張っても その人はまあほんのわずかな時間
1分  2分  3分 慈悲の気持ちを育てているならば
あるいは心が慈悲になっているならば
その人には何することもできない
ただ 向こうは栗を手で絞ったような感じになるだけやと
向こうは怪我するんであって
こちらには何のこともないんだ
そうやっていろんな方法で慈悲の気持ちを育てなさいと言うんですね
そこでみんなこの慈悲っていうのは宗教っぽくて
何か念じる なんていますか
お祈り文章だと勘違いしているんですね
慈悲の瞑想っていうのは
自分自身の人格リプログラミングすることなんです
今 汚れた貪瞋痴のプログラムで生きているんですね
貪瞋痴のプログラム で生きてると
結果は悩み 苦しみ 悲しみ
落ち込み それから罪を犯すこと
それから死後はガクンと落ちることなんです
みんな喜んで貪瞋痴のプログラムで生きているんです
喜んでて言ったっても他知らないんですね
生きるならばもうまず勉強して
よく食べて 健康な肉体でよく勉強して
いい仕事をして 金儲けて
結婚して 子育てをして
バカみたく死ぬことです
だって自分が育てた子供たちも出て行っちゃいますからね
自分の面倒を見ないんです
子供たちが結婚したら
自分たちの世界で同じバカなプログラム始めるんです
だからいつでも必ずハズレくじを引く
決まってハズレくじという当たりくじはない人生をやっているんですね
だから誰一人も知らないんですね
他の生き方あるんだよということを
もう当たりくじしかない生き方あるんだよと
ハズレは存在しないんだと
あの お正月とか近くなってくると
ガラガラガラ回すやつありますね
あれ回したら玉一つ落ちるんだけど
落ちる玉は必ず決まって大当たり
第1 一等賞で そういう生き方できるっていうことは
人類はわからないんです
それは貪瞋痴のプログラムでできるわけじゃないんですね
だから我々の心を新たにプログラミングして
自分自身が別人にならなくちゃいけないんです
これ キリスト教の言葉で言えば
新たに生まれ変わらなくてはいけないんです
今までの人間じゃないんです
例えば誰かが人が産む
人 子供を産む 子供を産んで
この子供を太郎と名前を付ける
太郎が貪瞋痴で生きている
そこでその太郎が慈悲の実践したら
新しい人間になるんです
もう別な太郎なんです
同じ人間ではないんです
その新しい人間はもうすべて当たりの人生になるんです
だからもうこの宇宙にいるすべての悪霊たちが来て
こいつを潰してやるぞと言ったっても
何のことない 自分たちが怪我するだけ
人類がこの人を不幸にさせてやるぞと思ってもできません
人類が不幸になるだけで
この一人の人間が光り輝いて生きていることになるんです
そこでそんなに狂暴な人間になるのかと思うかもしれません
ではないんです 慈悲の心なんです
慈悲の心には狂暴心はないんです
競争心は全くないんです
なんかもうすごい偉大なる存在で
自分という気持ちすらもう出てこないんです
だからこの理解できない
すごい清浄な 尊い清らかな人格になるんです
だからこれはキリスト教の言葉を借りて言うなら
使うならば生まれ変わることなんです
キリスト教の生まれ変わるっていうのはすごい単純なんです
でっかい水の中に放り込むだけで
2  3回放り込んで で もう全部中に入れちゃうんです
人をね 大人の場合は はい
それで生まれ変わりましたと
これ洗礼で そんな儀式で
神秘世界で宗教世界です
そこで慈悲の瞑想で自分が洗礼を受けて別人になるだけじゃいけない
そこはこの現代語でこう言ったんだけど
パーリ語ではヤーニカタ
ワット カタ アンチタ パリチタ
ススマラッダという風に専門用語を並べてであります
はい そういうわけで お釈迦様に対して
お釈迦様が推薦してやってくださいと頼んだ
お釈迦様に対するもう賛嘆でありでもあるし
あの慈悲の実践をこれからやってみようと思います
で 慈悲の実践のフルバージョン
今から行います で 私が一応言葉を喋りますけど
皆様方もネットで話を聞いている方々も
あのご一緒に参加して
唱えてみてください 途中でも喋れますが
あの あの この前のネット中継でそこをいろいろ誤解しているところがありまして
この誤解は誤解にならないと私が勝手に思ってるんだけど
誤解するのは自分の自我で考えると誤解になるんです
これは自我をいかに無くすのかと
いかに自分という このトラブルしか作らない
この概念を綺麗に削除するのかっていう目的で慈悲の瞑想なんですね
そこで今 貪瞋痴の自我の氷固まっている自分
そこからじわじわと人格を向上していかなくちゃいけない
だから そういう順番で
この慈悲の瞑想のバージョンを書いているんですね
はい 最初に私は幸せでありますように
誰だって自分幸せになりたい
幸せになりたいという素直な気分だけ考えてください
こういう風になったら幸せ
こういう風になったら幸せと思うのは間違いなんです
なぜならば それは貪瞋痴のプログラムなんです
貪瞋痴のプログラムでこうなったら幸せでしょう
あの人と結婚できれば幸せでしょう
あの仕事がもらっちゃえば幸せでしょうと思ったら
それが不幸の元 これで苦しく不幸になるんです
あれは貪瞋痴のメッセージなんです
ですから そうではなくて
幸せになりたい それで終わってください
はい 読み上げます 私は幸せでありますように
私の心に現れる悩み 苦しみが徐々に徐々に消えていきますように
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみの感情は人の心を苦しめます
苦しみである怒り 嫉妬
憎しみが私の心に起こりませんように
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみの妄想を育てないように努めます
私の思考が慈しみの思考になりますように
私は物事が常に変化して消え去るものであると観察します
私は過ぎ去った出来事にとらわれないように精進します
私は将来のことに執着して悩まない
不安にならない人間になります
私は 今ここでするべきことに集中します
そこでチャプター１なんです
そこでなんとなく幸福って何ですかと
ちゃんと書いてるはずなんです
幸せって何ですかと どこで幸せ壊れるのかと
どこで悩み苦しみが生まれるのかというアドバイス
全部入ってるんです それでなんで誤解するのかと
私にはわからないんです
これだけやれば いかなる精神病も治るはずなんです
だからこれ実践するということは
これを自分を改良改革するプログラムであると
完全にオーバーホールするプログラムであると
自分というボロ屋を潰して立派な宮殿を新しく作る世界だと理解して
このチャプターを繰り返し念じてみてください
念じて心に入れる 念じて心に入れる
で 心にフィードバックする
それで心が変わっていくんです
心が変わったら瞑想が成功しています
では 次のチャプターに行きます
私に他者に対する慈しみの気持ちが現れますように
そこでもうちょっと人格の拡大を考えているんです
チャプター１では 自分の中の問題を解決する
それからより大きい人間になろうとするんです
はい 続き続きます 私に他者に対する慈しみの気持ちが現れますように
他者に対して優しい心で対応することができますように
私の心に他を差別する気持ちが現れませんように
苦しい状況に遭遇しても忍耐することができますように
私の心が常に平安でありますように
私の心の汚れが徐々になくなりますように
私にありのままの事実を発見することができますように
私に真理を発見する智慧が現れますように
私に一切の現象に対する愛着がなくなりますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
ここでもう一つ 慈悲をそこで完成しているんです
チャプター２はチャプター２で完成しているんです
で 理解してください そこで私と思っちゃうと小さいんですね
だから私は他者も入れて大きい人格を作ってみるんです
だから私は私に対して取る態度が他人に対しても取れるような人間になることなんですね
で それで何を期待するのかで
自分の心が他人がいくらいても平安で安穏でいられることはできます
それから その瞑想が智慧の方に持っていくんです
智慧の方に持っていったら
智慧がある人に すべてのものことは無常であるありのままに発見する真理があったら
その人の慈悲の瞑想がそこで完成します
それはチャプター２ですね
で チャプター３に行きます
で ３と言ったっても ３
はすごい短い このチャプター３では
このすべての生命は兄弟という考え
これはあのブッダのこの輪廻の
教えを元にして慈悲の瞑想をすることなんですね
輪廻っていうのは あの過去は成り立たないではなくて
過去の起源 スタートポイントは成り立たない
要するに生命は輪廻転生する
将来はまだ現れてないんだから
将来は考えておかないんです
しかし 過去は終わった出来事だから
過去が事実としてあるんです
ある人には 一部の稀な人々に過去を
思い出してみることも記憶力もありますし
そこで過去はどこまでいたのかというと
そこのスタートポイントがないんです
だから無限という言葉でそこは済ませておくんです
無限と言ったってもあまり理解できないし
仏教用語では無限という言葉をあまり使わないんだけど
無始なる過去と言うんですね
ある初めが見当たらない過去
それぐらい過去で生命が生まれ変わって生まれ変わっていたならば
この世の中で自分と関係のない生命がいるはずがないんです
だから この短いこの人生だけに
この 60年  80年  90年ぐらいの
ちょっのわずかな時間に限って全てだと思っちゃうと
ものすごく心が乱れて
もう敵がいっぱいいて
困って困って仕方がなくなっちゃうんです
だから いえ 誰だって無始なる過去から回転しているんだと
だったら この生命は私の昔は親であったでしょう
父であったでしょう おじさんであったでしょう
私の子供であったでしょうと
なんとなく思っちゃう
思うと この全ての生命に対して対立がなくなるんです
壁が消えちゃうんです
それで人格が変わるんです
その目的でこのセクション念じるんです
はい いきます 私は全ての生命が私の兄弟であると思えるように精進します
私は全ての生命と私が平等であると思えるように精進します
私は全ての生命の幸福と繁栄を期待します
私は生命の間で調和が保たれるように精進します
それは短いフレーズで
ちょっと意図的に短くしましたけど
文章を書くときは 本来は結構長いんです
だからこの実践的にはこのヘビだ
嫌だではなくて ヘビさんですね
もしかすると私の母親でも過去でいたでしょうね
このヘビさんが昔私の娘
娘か娘でいたでしょうねとかね
そういう風に思ったりすると
なんかちょっと楽しくなっちゃうんです
あの 嫌だ 嫌いだって気持ちがなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると ヘビさん 無視はいてほしいと思えるようになるんです
だから今日 事務所であのなり
サリーちゃんの食べ物を出しているところを見たら
いっぱいアリが来てね
一生懸命食べ物を運んでいるんです
ね さあ アリちゃんが見ようともしない
そこら辺はなんで私の食べ物を持っていくんですか？といて
猫パンチでも打っちゃえばいいのに
見ようともしないんですね
アリがいるんだから まあ食べませんとかって
それで終わっちゃうんですね
で 我々人間どうですかね
ああ 嫌だ アリが来て なんか殺虫剤かけなくちゃとかね
それで恐ろしい態度取っちゃうんですね
だから事務所で困るとか
当然困りますけど しかし
アリさんたちも生命として見ると
アリさんたちがなんか食べ物を見つけて仕事中なんですね
大仕事 ちゃんとみんな列を組んできて
順番でソーシャルディスタンシングはやってないんだけど
アリはウイルスでかかれませんしね
ちゃんと運んで持っていくんですね
一人で運べるものは一人で運ぶ
これちょっと大きなって言っちゃうと
何のことなく 3匹ぐらい来て
はいよいしょと運んでいくでしょ
あれ あんなああいうことを見ると
私には不思議でたまらない
だってお互い喋ってもないんで
うるさくもないんです
それぞれサリーちゃんのカリカリを大きいものを運ぶ場合
まず小さいものから始まるんです
それからサリーちゃんが食べて落ちたもの
いわゆる唾液で濡れているものを次に運ぶんです
それ終わったらもう食べなかった
食べなかったものをいいものを最後に運ぶんですね
そちらにもちゃんと順番があるんです
だから もしサリーちゃんがご飯を食べようと思ったところで
アリたちを追い出しても
サリーちゃんには問題ない
いいもの残ってるんです
そこで食べないで待っていたならば
次にアリたちはそちらにも行って
これは 2 日間そのまま置いておいた後
ひとかけらもなくきれいにしているんです
人間が掃除しなくても
だからそれを見て あ 嫌だと言って自分が偉いという気持ちなんですね
でも 存在の権利はみんなにあるんです
生きる権利はアリにもあるんですね
だからそれを見て まあ輪廻の中で
もしかすると私はこのアリの
このアリの生命が私の父親であったかも
兄弟であったかも 私の子供であったいたかも
これは必ずありますよと
それぐらい輪廻は長いんだよと
言って 平和幸せを感じてみるんですね
そこで心理学的なポイントは
そういう他の生命は憎むことをやめなさいと
自分が偉いということはやめなさいと
ゴキブリを見たら 過去世で私のお母さんでしたでしょうと
という人間だから もしかするとこのゴキブリは昔
私のお母さんでしたかもしれませんし
お父さんであったかもしれませんし
思っちゃうと自分が偉いっていうこと消えちゃうんです
そこで人格が新しく 新しい人格になるんです
もう人間ではなく 尊い存在のになるんですよ
そういう目的でこのセクションあります
次のチャプターに行きます
それは同じチャプターの続きですが
お釈迦様がおっしゃった言葉ですからね
例えば私はゴキブリを見て
かつてお母さんであったかもしれませんね
あなたはと思ったっても
本当は自分で知らないんですね
だからそれ イメージトレーニングみたいなものになっちゃうんですね
しかし お釈迦様はそうおっしゃっているんだから
お釈迦様は過去を知る能力があったんだから
だからお釈迦様の言葉を念じて
さらに気持ちを強くします
私は釈尊の言葉を念じます
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の母ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の父ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の兄弟ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の子供ではなかった生命はいません
無始なる輪廻の中で 私の友人ではなかった生命はいません
釈尊の今生を尊んで 一切の生命に慈しみの気持ちを抱きます
全ての生命は私自身の父母
父母であると思います
全ての生命は私自身の兄弟であると思います
全ての生命は私自身の子供であると思います
全ての生命は私自身の友人であると思います
全ての生命は私自身の家族であると思います
全ての生命は幸福でありますように
ということで そのチャプターは終わります
で その一つのチャプターやれば
これ慈悲は瞑想完成しますよ
だから全てやらな だから私がよく言うのは
自分にピンとくる 何かちょっと頭の中で引っかかるチャプターを選んでやってくださいと
どんなチャプターでも完全に瞑想完成になるように組み立ててあります
瞑想を完成するということは
自分の心が綺麗に新しいプログラムに入れ替えることになります
次に いろいろたとえを使って
慈悲に達したらどうなるのかと理解するための慈悲の瞑想なんです
だから人々っていうのは
あのターゲットゴールを見て頑張る人々もいるんです
だから今度はこのゴールを先に決めて
ここを目指してくださいという瞑想になります
一は心は空気のように
だから人格を新しくプログラムし直したら
慈悲で再インストールしたならばどうなるんですかと
私が聞いたら  やべえと思っちゃうでしょうね
そう思うなよと ゴール見せてあげるんです
空気のように 空気と空気が
これ空気というんですかね
何の対立もなく一体になるように
私の慈しみの気持ちが全ての生命の心と一体になりますように
それだけでわかるでしょう
一切の生命の心の波長がわかるんです
自他の壁が消えているんです
だから今 私だけの心でしょう
ほんのわずかな波長で力がなくて
力がないんです これで全ての生命の波長と一緒になったら
あまりにも力強い人間になるんです
だから悪霊たちにはもう太刀打ちできないんです
皆様の携帯も電波を発信しますね
しかし あの あれですね
スカイツリーからも電波発信しているでしょ
あの電波の力 どうですかね
もう関東どこにも行きますから
だからもうそういう自分の心がものすごく強い波長の心になるんです
次の日 水と水が何の対立もなく一体になるように
私の慈しみの気持ちがすべての生命の心と一体になりますように
太陽の光が地球の隅から隅まで照らすように
私の慈しみの光がすべての生命の心を妨げなく照らせるように
制限なく慈しみを育みます
東西南北上下という六方に住む生命に対して
無限に留まることなく慈しみを育みます
ということで だいたいこの十方に慈しみを広げるという慈悲の瞑想がありまして
そこからポイントを取ってこの文章を作りました
だから十方って無限まで行くんですね
東西南北上下という六方なんですけど
十方とも言いますけどね
うん で 六方に行ったら
例えば上っていうのはどこまで続くんですかね
わからないね 自分の慈悲の気持ちがもう上にもう無限に広げてみる
下に無限に広げてみる
東西南北に無限に広げてみるっていうこと
で それすごくピンとこない言葉になりますけど
結構瞑想は成長します
だから水の例え 空気の例え
光の例えでで理解して進んでほしいと思います
次 あの慈しみの心がある人はどんな態度で生活するのかと
自我がなくなったらどうなるっていう問題扱った瞑想のバージョンです
心は大地の用に  このセクションはよくサーリプッタ尊者も使っていた
自分の戒めに使っていたフレーズで
で お釈迦様の教えですけどね
大地はいかなる清らかなものを捨てても
いかなる不浄なものを捨てても
喜ぶことも嫌がることもありません
私も他の生命の称賛 非難などを受けるときは
大地のような心を保ちます
生きていけるものが幸せでありますように
心は大地にしてしまう
大地どうですか？桜の花咲こうが
雑草が現れようが  トウモロコシがある
全然大地は大地でいるんです
誰の面倒を見てあげる
そこで不浄物はどんどん放り込もうか
大地はそこは受け止める
反対しません やがて我々は放射
あれ 何といいますか アトミックウェストというね
あの放射  放射性廃棄物
廃棄物 放射性廃棄物 放り込むんでしょうに
地球は反対しませんね
はい どうぞ だから 自分と他の生命の態度は
自分が消えたらそういうものになるんです
人はもう非難侮辱したって
別にまあその人の自由だからっていう感じになるんです
人は自分を称賛していると
その方はそう思っているんだから
別にということでいるんです
誰かがあなたなんか二度と見たくないと言ったら
まあそうでしょうねとかね
どうぞと その生命のその自由を認めてあげる
なんであんたそんなこと言うんですか？と
けしからんな言葉を言うなよと
もう道徳違反でしょう
失礼ですと言っちゃうと
慈悲の一かけらもないんです
相手を繕おうとしているんです
それは人権侵害なんです
誰かが私にを見て あなたのことはもう二度と見たくないと
もう大嫌いになりましたと言ったら
私は微笑んで あ そうですか
いいでしょう で終わらなくちゃいけないんです
そこで私に慈悲があるならば
私はすぐ大地が出てくるんです
自分が大地ですから それは権利あるんです
あの誤謬をしている権利があるんです
だからそこまで理解できれば
もう自我がわからないって言える？と私が聞きたいんです
はい 次のセクションは
この業の相続ということで
あの これはいろんな宗教がなんで生命があるのかという問題に引っかかっちゃったんですね
宗教家が原始時代で現れた宗教だから
科学の一欠けらもないし
地球は平らだと思っていたし
自分が住んでいる地方だけ世界だと思っていたしね
例えばね まあこのモーセスが書いた旧約聖書の文章もモーセス書いてないんだけど
その人々はそれだけ世界だとと思っているんですね
だから そんなもうイスラエルだけ世界やと思っている人々にとっては
人類は 生命はこの世に現れたというとわかるわけないでしょうに
インド人がすべての人間がインド人だけやと思っていたんです
だから神様が人間を作る場合は
シャトリ ブラフマーのワイシュードラという４つのカードで作ったんだと
あの連中は自分の周りしか知らなかったんですね
それ言ったバカたちが自分の社会で４つのカーストがあったんですね
生命は神が４つに分けたと
日本人が入ってなかったんです
アフリカ人が入ってなかったんでバカでしょうね
人類はアフリカで現れたんだけど
アフリカ人の世界ではカースト制度はないので
それは入ったのはあと最近なんで
イスラム教が入ってから
キリスト教が入ってから
アフリカの国が盗まれたんだからね
いろんな国々から来て
人の財産 国を盗んだんだから
まあもうハチャメチャになったんだけど
でないで その人々はすごく穏やかでおおらかで生活していたんです
だから今は黒人 白人差別までやる
この差別する権利あるんですかね
みんなホモサピエンスサピエンスでしょうに
だから最初のホモサピエンスできたのはアフリカっていうことは
今は科学的に言ってるんだから
これは正しいかどうかよくわからんだけど
それは間違っているという証拠は一つも出ていないんだから
だから人類のがたどったルートを見ると
ちゃんとアフリカから中国に行ったところやら
同じホモサピエンス 自分のスリランカにまで行ったルートがちゃんとあって
ヨーロッパの方に行ったルートちゃんとあって
で そこもそんな能力ない時代で
で インド人もカースト制度を作る
それも一部のインド人が
南インドの存在は知らなかった
南インドの人々の間でカースト制度はないんです
あるんだけど あの４つじゃないんです
だからそれが神が作ったと言うと
もうあまりにも笑い話になる
それでお釈迦様がもう科学者に知られない世界まで知っていたのです
宇宙の無限なる存在を知っていたのです
もう太陽なんかは永遠不滅じゃないと
もうこれはもう消えちゃいますよと知っていたのです
この この星団がね 現れて消えるんだよと
宇宙全体現れて消えるんだよと
そこまで知っていたのです
それで 生命とエネルギーは物質エネルギーと違うんだと
物質は物質で現れては消えて
現れて消えて それに合わせて生命エネルギーもいろんな形を作って現れたり消えたりする
だから物質 ユニバースが
コスモスが消えると生命も一緒に消えるわけじゃないんです
コスモスが消えるということは
コスモスのエネルギーが波長を変えたんです
そうすると生命とエネルギーもそれに合わせて波長を変えるのです
で そこまで知ってお釈迦様は説かれているのです
そこでお釈迦様が生命の波長っていうのは一定していないのです
均等ではないのです 例えば鉄を掘るならば
アフリカからあのアイアンオール取って工場でアイアン作る
ヨーロッパから取ってアイアン作る
日本からもあれ なんとか
なんて言いますか あの石には鉱石取って工場で砕いてアイアン鉄を作る
鉄見たら言える これは日本の土から出た鉄だとかね
これはアフリカから掘り出した鉄やとわからない
鉄は鉄です だから物質にはこの
同一性があるのです 例えば
水はその場所によって変わるんだけど
蒸留水だったら海から水を取って蒸留水を作る
日本のどこかに山から水を取って蒸留水
同じなんです 便所の水を汲んで蒸留水を作る
同じです ということは
水 水にはどんな水にでも同一性があるのです
生命にはそれがないのです
それはなぜかと誰にも説明できません
例えば 人間の観察能力が乏しいだけで
例えばアリの群れを見ると
アリ一匹一匹に個性があるのです
私は調べたことがあるのです
個性があるのです ミツバチもみんな働き蜂でワンパターンで仕事をするんだけど
違うんです 各ミツバチに個性があるのです
会社で同じ仕事をしたからといって個性は消えるわけじゃないのです
だから観察するとそれ見えるはずなのです
でも 昔私はもう結構若い頃
いろいろないたずらするんだけど
私はよくやったことは
このアリがずっと高速道路を作って歩くんですね
目はないんだから 感覚で道路を作っていくのですね
大体信号は匂いで取るのです
それで私はもうスリランカにいる時はもうほとんど体が汚れたままで
放っておいても綺麗にしたって意味がないんだからね
そこで自分がこのアリがいるルートで
指でしっかりこうやって触って触って触って触るというか
削るんです 自分の指で
だから自分の体の朝 朝
朝 汗とかね 汚れとか体の脂とか
そこらへん塗っちゃいますでしょ
そこでアリたちが来て
あ 高速道路を切られているんだと
で 止まるんです 進めないんです
1センチも幅がないんで
指の幅だから まあ 1センチぐらいかな
そこでそちらで来るわ来るわ
止まるわ 来る来る これこちら側もアリたちが来て来て止まるわ
それで私はじーっとアリたちを見ているんです
反応はバラバラなんです
止まってじーっと待ってる人もいる
あちらこちらあちら来ると回る
ぐるぐる回っているアリもいる
なんでそんなにワンパターンだったら
みんなじーっと待っていた方がいいでしょう
なんであちら群れが出来上がるんですかね
だって 前のアリが止まったら後ろのアリも止まっちゃえばいいでしょう
そうないんです それで群れを作っちゃうんです
そこでウロウロしていると
その中でアリ一匹ぐらい
進んでみるんです あの私の指の油が入っているところに入ってみるんです
入ってちょこちょこって
また怖くて逃げる また一匹が来て
もうちょっと進んで行くんです
それで三回ぐらいやってみると
元の高速道路を見つけるんで
あのアリが見つけたら普通進っていくんです
そこで勇気のある好きのアリもその道路で行くんです
これで三匹目のアリが行ったら
もう高速道路出来上がっちゃって
それからザーッとまたフェスが始めて
あの群がったことは消えちゃうんです
だからそれでアリにも個性あるということでしょうに
そこでもう開拓者がいるんですよ
新しい道を開拓しようではないかとかね
そういうわけで すべての生命に個性があるんです
無生物にすらあるんです
それはどう説明するのかと
それで物質と違う働きなんですね
生命は で 物質と依存しているんだけど
自分が別のエネルギーの流れ
物質は別のエネルギーの流れ
そこでこの生命のエネルギーは心のエネルギーといって
この心には心が行う行為によって道が変化するんだと
だから一個一個の心は自分の行為によって自分の道が決める
そこでいろんな心が集めて似たような行動をするかもしれませんだけど
だいたいそんなに派手なことを心にはできません
だから どんな心が行動しても
だいたいワンパターンになります
だから似たように見えるんです
アリの群れは同じく見えるように
蜂の巣が同じくミツバチの巣が同じく見えるようになるんだけど
で だから各生命が自分の流れが自分の行為によって作っているんです
ですから今物体持ってますけど
から物体をもらう場合も
これ世界から地水火風もらいますからね
もらうのは私 心なんですね
だから私の心にどれぐらい物質取ることはできるのか
その物質はどのように組み立てるのかと
その物質を使ってどんなことをするのかということは
心の管轄なんです だから人間見ても体がバラバラ
同じ親の子供も体がバラバラ
能力はバラバラ 体力はバラバラ
統一はない 生命にはないんです
統一というか同一 パーフェクトアイデンティティはないんです
だから個だと言うんです
個はその個の心の働きによって成り立つのです
それは仏教専門用語で業と言うのです
だから一人の個の責任は
その業のことなんです
だから一切生命は業によって業に支配されて
業に作られて 業の好き勝手に回転しているものやと思っちゃうと
すべての生命はみんな同じこっちゃと
自分が偉いわけでも 他人が卑しいわけでもないんだと
この極振り目という必要はないんだと
心は回転する次第でどうにもなるんだよと
それで業というファンクションが
仏教はすべての宗教は答え見つからなかったし
科学者も見つかっていないし
科学者はまだ心の研究に入ってないし
ですから それは他宗教でもないし
科学本読んでも出てこない話ですね
業ということは だから次のチャプターは皆は業を相続しますということで
だから悩む必要はない
苦しむ必要はない 落ち込む必要はない
見栄張る必要はない 自分と自我ある必要もない
ただ業という宇宙的にコスモス的に働く心のエネルギーのことであると
はい いきます 疲れて見えなくなりましたので
すべての生命は自分の業を相続します
自分の業に管理されて生きています
各生命が受ける幸不幸はその生命の業の力によるものです
ですから 私は私より豊かな人を見るたびに
過去に善行為をした人であると思い
喜びを感じます 私より不幸に思える人を見ると
生命は無明のせいで罪を犯すのだと理解し
自分が罪を犯さないように気つけます
この文章は結構誤解するみたいですね
だから豊かか不幸かっていうのは自分の主観の判断なんです
だから自分に心がある
このだらしない心が この人はすごい豊かですねとか思っちゃうんです
それで心が汚れるんだから
別にその人の業でしょうにと
だから別に良かったねと思っちゃった方がいいんじゃない？ということで
慈悲の気持ちを持つ それでこの人は不幸ですね
かわいそうですねと思う場合もある
それは自分という心がそう思うんです
その人は不幸かかわいそうかわかりません
はっきり言えば ある人が生まれつき目が見えない
私がこの人は不幸だなと勝手に思ったっても
その人は自分のことを不幸やと思っているかどうか分からないんです
それは関係ない 私の心そう思ったんだから
そこで私はあの傷跡を治すんです
あ こうやって不幸になるのは業の結果
悪いことをすると結果にそうなる
だから人は悪いことをしてはいけません
それは人に言う権利がないんだから
私が悪いことをしないことにすると
自分の戒めにその現象を使うんです
次 不幸に陥っている生命に対して哀れみの気持ちを抱きます
協力する 助ける気持ちを起こします
で終わり それでエゴの錯覚
たくさんあります 次 慈悲の瞑想をしたければ
次のチャプターでエゴという錯覚があります
エゴっていうのは自我
自分がいるんだという
特に宗教の世界が必ず強調するポイントなんです
宗教は一回エゴを正当化
必死に正当化するんです
あらゆる単語を使って正当化するんです
だから世界は人に魂があることは当たり前だと思っているんです
そこで面白いことは 魂があるのは人間だけだと
そうやってエゴをできるだけ強化する
ブッダはまず魂があるかないか調べなくちゃいけないと説くものなんです
だからエゴの錯覚で全ての罪が起こるんです
だからこの他宗教は純粋に魂
純粋魂作ってくださいと
魂を汚れているんだから清らかにしなさいと言ったっても
魂という概念が全ての悪の元なんです
仏教で発見したのは 魂ということは錯覚ということなんです
勘違いということです
私は他より優れていると感じることは高慢です
私はたと同等だと思うことは同等慢です
私は他より卑しい存在であると思うことは卑下慢です
慢とは私のエゴの錯覚から起こるのです
私はエゴの錯覚が心に現れないように精進します
私は慢により現れる対立
悩み 争いから離れるようにと精進します
だからエゴという恐ろしい鬼から身を守ることも慈悲の瞑想になるんです
あ これは自我だ これは自我だと自分に言い聞かせちゃうと
この人はなんか面倒くさいなと思った瞬間で自我がないでしょ
あ こちらのエゴだ 自我だと思ったら消えて自我が出てくるんです
だから自我が変わるたびにエゴが割り込んでいるんです
それ錯覚やと思ったら
全ての対立がなくなります
で 頑張りましょう 次に行きます
ちょっとスピードを上げます
苦しみ 世界で苦しみなく
これは仏教の人々の生き方を見て
慈悲の実践する方法なんです
特に仏道の人々 悟りに達している人の生き方があるんです
それを見ると羨ましいと思うんじゃなくて
それを見て自分を真似るんです
世界は欲によって苦しんでいることを観察して
私は欲を控えることに精進します
世界は怒りによって苦しんでいることを観察して
怒りのない心で生きるように精進します
世界は嫉妬によって苦しんでいることを観察して
嫉妬のない心 生きるように精進します
世界は恨みによって苦しんでいることを観察して
恨みのない心で生きるように精進します
世界は物惜しみによって苦しんでいることを観察して
物惜しみのない心で生きるように精進します
世界は自我を張るから苦しんでいることを観察して
自我を張らない心で生きるように精進します
世界は見栄を張るから苦しんでいることを観察して
見栄を張れない心で生きるように精進します
世界は一切の現象は無常であると気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は無常であると認めて生きるように精進します
世界は一切の現象は苦であると気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は苦であると認めて生きるように精進します
世界は一切の現象は無我であると気づかないので
苦しんでいることを観察して
一切の現象は無我であると認めて生きるように精進します
私の心に悩みが起こりませんように
私の心に苦しみが起こりませんように
私の心は平安でありますように
私の心に安らぎが現れますように
私に悟りの光が現れますように
このポイントはお釈迦様の言葉で完成するので
そちらにお釈迦様の純粋な言葉を入れているんです
カンティーパレマンタポーティティカー
忍耐と堪忍は最高の修行であります
だから今この忍耐 堪忍のことを教えたんですね
ニッバーナパレマンスカン
涅槃は究極の幸福であります
はい これであの涅槃の境地を説明している慈悲の瞑想です
えーと 最後になりましたと思います
慈しみの拡大 そのまま読みます
私の上の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の下の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の前の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の右の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の後ろの方向に住んでいるすべての生命
私の左の方向に住んでいるすべての生命
幸福で安穏でありますように
怒り 来る 憎しみ 怒り 憎しみ
恨みから自由になりますように
互いに慈悲喜捨の気持ちで接し合えますように
願い事が叶えられますように
心の汚れが徐々になくなりますように
すべての生命に苦しみを乗り越えることができますように
はい それで慈悲の瞑想を終了しました
だから単純な宗教でいう愛とかね
そんなもんじゃなくて
これはすごいプログラムなんです
だから慈悲の瞑想も智慧と
それから戒律と あのえーと
テトリスにしておかないとダメなんです
だからそれすべて入れて完成しているんです
この慈悲の瞑想をやってる人は戒律を犯せません
犯せなくなっちゃうんです
それから理解し 理解が深くなっていくんです
一切の精神病気が治りまして
空気のような人になるんです
地球の空気と同じくなるんです
大陸にはリミットあるんだけど
空気にはリミットがないんです
そのようになるんです
はい そこはお釈迦様が我々に教えた慈悲の世界です
はい ありがとうございます
はい それでこのウェーサーカ祭りのポイントはもう毎年同じ繰り返しています
で お釈迦様の人間としての誕生を祝います
なぜならば それは最後の生まれ
輪廻転生して みんな何か目的を目指して走っているんです
この目的何か誰もわからない
誰だって途中で死ぬ みんな何のために生きてるんでしょうかと自問しているんだけど
それ見つからずに死ぬ
そうするとまた繰り返し同じパターン繰り返しちゃうんです
また生まれて 犬になって
猫になって 蛇になって
大体みんなこの自分一番嫌がる生命
嫌がる生命になるんです
生命は差別してはいけませんよ
差別すると差別された側の気持ち経験しないでしょう
経験させちゃいます あ
ゴキブリは嫌だとと言って
スリッパでね パシッとやっちゃうとゴキブリの立場わからないね
次にゴキブリになってみるんです
どうですかと 経験しなさい
学びなさいと 学べないでしょうに
だから新たな人生っていうのは新たな宿題をいただいたんです
そこで人間だけはこの宿題完成することができるんです
みんな自分の肉体の宿題も終わらずに死んでしまうんです
だからお釈迦様は肉体の宿題は簡単だと
年取って死ぬ 年取って病気になって死ぬ
それだけだと これから猿回しみたいにくだらんことをやるんだけど
どうでもいいやと アメリカの大統領になったり
日本の総理になったり
ホームレスになったり
そんなのは大したことはないんだと
誰だって年取って病気になって死ぬ
さようなら 終わり だから肉体のプログラム気にするなよと
心を見て心を完成しなさいと
人間にしかできませんよという宿題なんです
だからブッダは生命でこの宿題完成する道を教えたんです
お釈迦様は菩薩として虫なる過去から修行して修行して
最後にでは最後の宿題をやって完成するんだと生まれたんです
だからこの菩薩としてマーヤ夫人のお腹に入って生まれたことが
お釈迦様のもうラストスパートで勝利なんですね
だから勝利を意味するんです
すべて揃って宿題完成する
最後の終わりになりました
終わったと これで終わりだと
だから偉大なる勝利を意味するんです
それが人類にも幸福になるんです
ブッダが現れたこと ですから
お釈迦様が人間で生まれなかったらどうにもならんですね
ブッダになるのは人間なんです
他の生命はブッダになれないんです
だから一人の生命が完成しなくちゃいけない宿題は
人間という肉体形でないと完成することはできないんです
だから輪廻転生だから回転して回転して
もし人間に回転してきたら
さっさと宿題完成しなくちゃいけないんです
はい そういうことで 最後の勝利という意味をするので誕生を祝うんですね
だからそれはパーリ語で
お釈迦様もこういう風に唱えたと言ってますけど
生まれたすぐ赤ちゃん
どうなのかよくわからないんだけどね
人間に理解できないことはたくさん起きますよと
ブッダには いわゆる考えるなよと
あのブッダに対しての項目
お釈迦様はこういうこういう項目がありますから
それはありえない 稀有なこと
まれなことで 理解しても頭が狂うだけだと
だからそのまま理解して覚えておいてくださいということで
一つは生まれて生まれた時は体が汚れていなかったこと
ありえないね えーって
忘れてくださいと あなた方理解できない
それはもうありえない
もうお釈迦様の赤ちゃんの体は汚れていなかった
それから歩いたと ね 歩けるないでしょう
それはありえない 稀有なことで
ブッダにしか起こらない
だから議論しないでそれを置いておいてください
この項目はと で 歩いてそんなにたくさん歩いたわけじゃないんですよ
もうほんのちょっと七歩ぐらいですね
で 言葉を喋ったんですね
その言葉もそう誰にも理解できない言葉で
今もこの翻訳する人々が理解できない言葉になっていますね
毎年言いますから 今回も言います
アゴハマスミローカッス
ゼットハマスミローカッス
セットハマスミローカッス
アヤマンティマージャティ
ナティダニプナンバウ
だからこのユーガ独尊という芸なんですね
えらい威張っているように見えるんですね
威張ってなくて ありのままのことを言っているんです
ローカッサというの一切の存在の中で
アッゴ一番トップな生命体になりました
セットっていうのは一番優れている生命体になってしまった
ジェットハマシローカ
すべての生命の中で自分が先輩になる先輩になってしまった
で これが終わりですと
これ以上輪廻転生しませんというブッダの勝利宣言なんです
はい それから我々は次にお釈迦様が悟ったこと
ウェーサーカマッスルでお祝いというか
念じるんですね で 悟ったっていうことは
宿題を完成しまった 三十五歳で
もうやることなくなった
もうそれでもう肉体が滅びるまで待つ
待ってるだけ この間で伝道しました
だから悟った時 その日ではないんだけど
だいたい 1週間ぐらい禅定状態だったんだけど
で 生命と世界コスモスはどう成り立っているのかと考えたんです
悟ってからなんです モーセスみたいな原始人が
まず神が天と空とあれやこれやと作ったっていうようなくだらない話ではないんです
申し訳ない それでも因縁によって成り立つんだと
これでボスはないんだと
誰かが誰かをやるんじゃないんだと
この世の中で因縁によって物事は起こるんだと
じゃあ私が喋るとか成り立たないんです
これは肉体の因縁によって声が出てくる
声が 心が いろんな波長
いろんな波を押しながら
どんな音にするのかと
そこで管理立て作って結果が出るだけです
だからこっちの私が喋ることは成り立ってないんです
私が喋ったからって皆様が理解するわけじゃないんです
そちらにも因縁 因果法則が働いているんです
そうやって全ての物事は因果法則によって成り立っているんだよと生命の現れを発見したところで
宇宙のコスモスの現れ
なくなる道を発見したところで
やっとお釈迦様が自分が悟ったことの勝利宣言するんですね
それは皆様は覚えているんです
じゃあ唱えます アネーカジャーティサンサーランサンダーヴィッサンアニッビサンガーカーカンガヴェーサント
ドゥッカ ジャーティ プナン プナン ガハーカーカ ディットー シー プンゲハンナカーシー サッバテー パースカ
バンガ ガハ クータン ヴィサンキタ ヴィサンカーガタント チッタン タンナーナン カエ マンジャカーティということで
そこで勝利宣言 アネーカ ジャーティ サンサーラン
無始なる過去から この輪廻の中でサンダーヴィッサン走り回ったよと
ブッダは菩薩が何か探していたんだよと
限りなく私は探っていたんだよと
サンダーヴィッサン アニッビサン
何を探していたんですかと
この家を作る人を探していたんだと
家っていうのは生命ということなんです
なんで生まれるのかと
なんでいろんな形で自分が輪廻転生
自分ではなくて もう輪廻転生起きているのかと
誰かがこれ作っているんですかと
このエネルギーシステムが壊れると
変わって別のエネルギーシステムが現れる
探していたんだと ガハーカーカ ディットーシー
見つけたよと 汝を見つけた
生命を作る人 そこであえて人格化して喋るんです
プナゲーハンナカーシー
これ誰ですかと 人格化しているんだけど
渇愛なんです ここに渇愛があるんです
これだから新しい命が現れるんです
こいつやと生命を作るのはと
渇愛だと 渇愛は天にあるわけじゃないんです
自分持ってるんです で
プナゲーハンナカーシー
サッバーテー パースカ バッガ ガハ クータン ヴィサンギタン
五蘊を作るために必要な基本的な材料を壊しちゃったと
いわゆる渇愛壊ししまったと
無明を破ったと もう組み立てないんです
それでヴィサンカーラ ガタン チッタン
心は一切概念から自由になったと
お釈迦様の心には概念思考ないんです
空のようにと言わない
空というと言ったら物質ですからね
宇宙の心やと言った方がいいかもしれません
無限広大無辺の宇宙の心のようになった
それも仏教は否定する喩えです
皆さんが理解できるように言っただけで
だから空気のような心ではなくて
虚空のような心になりましたと
それには何も作れないでしょう
タンナーナン カヤマジャカも渇愛をなくなりましたと
サンカーラから無きの
消えちゃってっていうお釈迦様の勝利の宣言
そこで我々は涅槃もウェーサーカ祭りで考えているんです
涅槃とは このそれから 45 年間
この肉体を持っていたんですね
だから肉体を持ってずっと説法していたんですね
だからお釈迦様って我々に見えるあの個人が
あの肉体が呼吸止まったところで分解して物体も消えてしまったんです
もう心はもうすごくすごく前に 35歳で消えちゃったんだからね
でも物体と一時的な働く心があったんだからね
それもそれでカーッと消えていっちゃったんですね
だからそこは 3番目の勝利になるんです
だから最後はお釈迦様が言ったのは
お釈迦様のことじゃなくて
我々のことを心配して
不放逸に頑張ってください
すべて無常やと ブッダたるこの体みたいにあなたたち見えるでしょうにと
もうすぐなくなり 壊れますよと
すぐ呼吸が止まりますよと
で 最後の言葉 それは偈ではないんです
ハンダダニ ビッカウェー アマンタヤ ミウォ ワヤ ダンマ サンカーラ アッパマーデーナ サンパーデータということで
もう最後にあなた方に喋りますと
ハンダダニというのは
ではもうあなた方に告げます
すべての現象は消え去るものです
不放逸でいわゆる気づきを実践しなさいと
アッパマーダというのはサティの実践することなんです
だから解脱の鍵はサティの実践なんです
最後のその言葉を喋ってから喋らなかったんです
そのまま禅定に入って
第4禅定に入って お釈迦様が呼吸を止めたんです
はい ウェーサーカの三大事件はそこで終了です
長い時間本当にありがとうございます
えーと 多田さんという方ですね
感情ではなく できるだけ理性で生きるためにはどうすればいいでしょうか
ということですね  まずね
あの やっぱりすべて実験ですからね
まあよくやっていることは
これが感情で言ったの
感情でやったの あるいは理性でやったのかと
まず自己観察すれば うまくいくと思いますね
だから自己観すると やったことは理性だったら成功しているんですね
感情だったらどこかで後味が悪いということは見えてくる
そういうふうに実験していけば
感情なく理性で喋ったり
考えたり 判断したりすることはできるようになると思います
はい  はい それから三原さんという方の質問なんですけど
この方在家の方で 質問は 2つですね
仕事中にどのようにヴィパッサナーのサティを入れるのが正しいでしょうか？集中瞑想のようにスローモーションをしていると仕事になりませんということですね
それからもう一つは 在家として仕事をする行為と出家の解脱を目標とする道が相容れないように思いますが
在家で解脱まで達した方はいますか？という
えっとですね 何でもかんでもこちらからすべてこうしなさい
ああしなさいという命令する世界じゃないんですね
仏教では人に命令しません
人は自由です やるかやらないか
その人が決めなくちゃいけないんです
だから そこを忘れていて考えると
そういうふうに質問が現れてくるんです
我々はヴィパッサナーのやり方を教えます
やるかやらないか その個人の自由です
そこで集中瞑想の時はこういうやり方で
仕事中私も瞑想したいんですかなと思ったら
ご自分でどんな風にした方が瞑想になるのかと判断しなくちゃいけないんですね
それで正しいかいないかも
私に聞く必要すらないんです
なぜならば 人に命令しない
仏教は 理由は 生命に命令
命令することは成り立たないんです
生命 各生命は自分の勝手で自分の本心で生きているんです
ただ仕方がないんだから
一時的に人の話も聞いたりする
アリ塚のアリたちがもうアリになっちゃったんだだからしょうがなく
仕方がなく 自分に与えられた仕事をやっているだけで
管理されているわけじゃないんです
なんか管理されているように見えるだけ
だから私はアリにも個性があると言ったんです
ミツバチにも個性があるんです
女王蜂にすべて管理しているわけじゃないんです
女王蜂は自分の群れ 何匹がいるかわからないでしょ
女王蜂は下向きに仕事をしているだけで
卵を産んで卵を産んでいる
それで忙しい だから 生命には他の生命を管理すること
指令することは成り立たない
一時的に まあ仕方がなく
お互いの合意によって管理みたいな一時的な錯覚が起こります
一時的なんです 私は日本にいるんだから
日本の法律と日本の決まり
しきたりに従っているんだけど
飛行機に乗って国に行った途端
さようならでしょ 日本の法律もしきたり
何も関係ない あの国に入った途端
そちらのあのフォーマットを受け取らなくちゃいけないんです
それだけ だから このみんなよく失敗するところで
今日ウェーサーカの式典だから
よく覚えてください 私ももうすごい言葉を間違ったり
厳しいことを言ったりするんだけど
基本的に指令する権利がないんです
私はこちらに座っているこのお坊さんにも昨日夜言いましたけど
あなた方はスリランカ人に五戒を教える教え方間違っているんだと
だから誰も守っていないんだと
正しく教えればみんな守りますよと
たとえて言ったのは 殺生するなかれと言ったら
殺生したくてたまらなくなるんだよと
お前何様ですかと 私に指令するのはと
だから たとえお釈迦様が直々来て殺生するなかれと言っても
殺生するんです だからお釈迦様そう言わせてないんです
お釈迦様おっしゃったのは
殺生する仕組みなんです
自分で自我があって 俺だけ幸せであればいいやと
それで怒り 嫉妬 憎しみがあって
他の生命の権利を奪う
その結果として あなたの生きる権利が失ってしまう
だから わかりやすく言えば
生きていきたいんだから
早死になる道を選んだことになる
ですから 提案としては
殺生をやめる方が正しい答えになる
はい 返ってくださいと
それだけ 仕組みを教えた
その人に殺生する自由もある
殺生しない自由もある
もしその人が えっ こんなバカなこと
今日から殺生しないぞと決めたら素晴らしい人間なんです
お釈迦様おっしゃったんだから
まあしょうがないな 嫌々でも守ろうと言うと
なんか力がないんです
智慧が現れてこないんです
誰かが横から来てね お釈迦様の言うことを聞く必要はないよと
もっと立派な人々がいるでしょうとかね
あの人は億万長者でしょ
窃盗しているんだから
あんた貧乏でしょうにと
そう言っちゃうと やっぱりと行く可能性あります
しかし あの風に教えたら
窃盗するかしないか 自分で決めるならばすごく違うんです
だからヴィパッサナー瞑想であろうが
解脱に達することであろうか
教え方は仏教では一貫しているんです
人に命令しない 仕組みを教える
ですから解脱に達するプログラムを教える
で その人はどんな世界環境で生きているのかと私はわからないし
私にとって知る必要もありません
だからその決めた人が自分の社会環境をチェック考えて
自分の人間関係 あれやこれやと計算して
どこで煩悩生まれるのか
どこで怒るのか どこで失敗するのかという自分の宿題して
自分で自分の心を清らかにしなくちゃいけないんです
だから 自分に自分しかないということは
仏教でよく言っているで
アッターヒアットノーナと
あなたの救いはあなたですよと
それはすごい言葉なんです
要するに 一切の生命の中で
一個の生命に 他の生命に指令する権利がないんです
だから この神を信じている人々にはそれを理解できないんです
あれは奴隷システムなんです
奴隷時代で現れた宗教なんです
奴隷とマスターがいる
主人が主人がいる だから奴隷は主人言う通りにやるしかない
キリスト教はよく使う
たとえ話は羊飼いでしょう
イエス様がグッドシェパードなんです
良い羊飼いです 奴隷でしょ
だからまだ文化 人類は文化的に発展していないんだから
ものすごい奴隷精神というのはまだまだ残っているんです
民主主義といっても奴隷システム
共産主義といっても奴隷システム
資本主義といっても奴隷システム
この奴隷システム 日本でも奴隷システム
ある一部のグループしか選挙に出ない
一部のグループしか議員さんにならない
誰が総理になるのかというと
初めからもう決まっていて
すごい優秀な人間いくらでもいるでしょうに
すごい人格するコネがなければ
政治家の関係ある誰か親戚でなければアウト
だからこの奴隷システムですよ
人間我々作っているのは
だから このブッダが教えたあなたの救いはあなただよという言葉は
まだまだ理解できなくなっているんです
だから私たちは人類に革命を教えているんです
人類いまだかって知らなかった世界を教えているんです
一個の生命は他の生命に迷惑をかけない世界を教えているんです
母親は子供に指令しない世界
子供が母親にガチャガチャガチャわがまま言って
母親を奴隷にしようとしない世界を教えているんです
それにはこれが必要です
理性が必要です だから
皆様にはいろいろ失敗は起こると思いますよ
もうずっと生きてきた癖があるんだから
だから 一人一人で 他人にあまり余計なことを言わないで
指令しないで 命令しないで
差し付けしないで 自分自身で判断してください
だから 仕事中でもヴィパッサナー瞑想やりたければ
どういうふうにやるべきかとご自分で判断してください
仕組みは教えます 妄想がなければ
仕事中 仕事中は思考が必要です
瞑想中は思考もダメです
集中瞑想では仕事をしているとか
思考が必要です だから思考が必要な分だけにして
妄想をやめるためにはどうすればいいかと
よくご自分の環境で判断してください
何人か運転する方々は
私に運転するときどう瞑想すればいいかと聞いたことがあるんです
運転生まれて運転したことは一度もない
私は ステアリングホイールを触ったことはありますよ
もう止まってる車の そういう私がどうやって運転するときにヴィパッサナー瞑想のやり方を教えられる？だから私に仕組みだけ言える
妄想しちゃうとまずいよ
だから運転する時でも妄想しないで
必要な思考だけにリミットされてやってみてください
やり方は自分で考えてください
だけなんです 私に教えられるのはやり方っていうか
この仕組みだけなんです
で それから何でしたっけね
まあまあ 一応テキストを見ると
在家の世界と出家の世界っていうのは差が見えますけど
今日も仏教の論文 新しい論文を出すために情報が入りますから
あの Why ブッダトート Why ブッダトート to the monks only という論文もあって
面白くないんだからダウンロードしなかったんだけど
なぜお釈迦様は比丘たち出家だけに説法したのかというね
で  これはなぜですかね
あれはお釈迦様に聞かなきゃわからないしね
いろいろ言えますよ だから論文読んでないけどね
お釈迦様から説法を聞いたのは
みんな修行者なんですね
もともと ほとんど  それはあったんだから
しょうがないでしょうに
在家に説法したら 在家の一部は出家したんです
出家はお釈迦様の仲間のグループだから
仲間にたくさん喋る 在家の会う時間短いんだから
在家に喋った説法は短い
それで奥義を覚えておいて
次の世代に渡したのは出家だから
自分たちで覚えている奥義は全部出家の世代に残っちゃったんです
だから在家に教えた説法は
ほんのわずかしか残ってないんです
そういう歴史的な出来事やと思うし
そういう風にこの現代我々は
まあこれ問題はあるんだけど
当然ね それで失敗する人々も結構いるし
目覚めるためにはもう隠れて
もう出家して もう道場に隠れてやらなくちゃいけないとか思っている人もいるしね
その人々は忘れている理由は
道場に隠れても 人々は食べるものやら住むところ用意しなきゃどうする？だから
そこは何で無視するんですかね
義務がないんです 道場にお布施を持って行って
必要なものを全部持っていって
無料で瞑想できるように環境を作ってあげるとかね
だからこの変です だからこのそれだったら
それなりにすごい真剣真面目に修行する義務があるし
でお布施をする方々に対して
慈悲をひっちゃめちゃ
慈悲を実践して実践して幸福を願わなくちゃいけない義務が生じるし
だから仕事なし ただで食うっていうことは成り立たないんです
結構そう思っている方々もいる
何でも正で揃っているならば瞑想できません
こんな無責任で まあそういうことだから
この現代的に言えば このブッダの時代でももう在家は悟ったんです
もう一つ論文があったんで
それは私もよく勉強に使ったある先生の論文なんで
それもダウンロードしなかったんですけど
あの それはこの先生アラハントホワイトアラハントインブッダスタイムという論文で
おそらく仏教百科ペディアに百科事典の記事
あのもう一度出したものやと思いますからね
それもダウンロードしなかったんですけど
内容はあったと思いますけどね
だからお釈迦様のお父様も阿羅漢になったし
出家してないんです だからまあ悟りっていうのは心のプログラムを変えることだから
着ている服でこれ変えましょうと
変でしょうに 白い服を着ているか
こういう茶色の服を着ているかということによって悟るか悟らないかって決める
何考えてるんですかね
だからあの服に感情が入っているならば問題です
例えば ある人がもうピアスつけている
私は一度もピアス着けてるで
なんであんたそんなだらしない格好で瞑想に行く？言ったことはないんです
私 それ見えるとも見えることもないんです
しかし ピアスつけて それで俺がもうかっこつけてると思ったら
そこは煩悩が働きます
そこで悟れなくなっちゃうんです
これはフランスのブランドの服だよと思っちゃうとアウト
そこで煩悩が働いているんです
でなきゃ 何着ていたっても全然問題ないんです
で 体中アクセサリーがあったからといって
ただ決まりでつけるものやと思っているならば
もう全然関係ないんですね
ダンマパダにもゲイとあります
アランカトーチェイピサマンチャレイもう体ハチャメチャおしゃれしていたっても
心がサマンチャレイ心が安定しているならば阿羅漢だよ
で 心に悪がなければ悪のない状態を作れば
それ言ったのはある軍人の人が
あの 1週間あの戦争があって
それで勝って勝利しちゃったんですね
それで王様がご褒美で 1週間休みあげて
あのヘランの踊り子さん一人もあげたんです
すごい上手な踊りの女性なんです
で そのグループと一緒に
この人は 1週間食べて飲んで遊んで遊んで
ハチャメチャ欲に溺れた生活をしていたんです
しかし 自分を楽しめるために
あの女の人はすごい苦労していたんです
この男にそれわからなかったんです
この人はお腹いっぱい食って飲んで
じゃあ踊りましょうとかあれこれ言うんだけど
あの女の人はご飯食べると難しい踊りができないんです
体は振ったり ぐにゃぐにゃ曲げたり
いろいろことしなくちゃいけないんでしょ？だから彼女は自分の芸のためにほとんど食べなかったんです
王様の場合は呼ばれたら行ったら行くだけでしょ
これは王様の指令で付きっきりでしょ
だから毎日踊らなくちゃいけない
朝も昼も夜もわからない
彼女が死んじゃったんです
そのショックで そこで目覚めたんです
この人は 自分には見えなかった世界があったと
表面だけではないんだと
で また王様にどう報告すればいいんですかね
王様の財産殺しちゃったんだから
これでもまたすごい派手な像に乗っちゃって
で 悩み果てている時 お釈迦様が言って教えたんです
真理は そのまま悟ったんです
阿羅漢になったんです
阿羅漢になったらもうその日で亡くなるんです
在家の人は その人もその日で亡くなったんです
そこであの人の最後の 1週間は最低最悪でしょうとみんな言うんです
だから地獄は確実だと
お釈迦様が違うよと あれほど派手で
あれほどアクセサリーいっぱい体に付けて軍人司令官でねいても
その人の心は安穏に達していたよ
だから聖者で阿羅漢で亡くなったとお釈迦様が発表したケースなんですね
だからお釈迦様には その当時の社会環境によってどうしかなかった可能性はあるんだけど
仏教は科学であって心理学なんですね
ですから あなたどんなご飯食べるのかと
パン食べるのか 芋を食べているのかと関係ないんです
パン食べて芋芋食べて瞑想できなかった方からは
パンやめてご飯にしてください
それだけご飯食べたら胃がもたれて瞑想できるところではなかったならば
ご飯やめてくださいと
そんな程度の話なんです
だから誰だって妄想をやめて
無駄な思考もやめて 瞬間瞬間のことを確認して生きてみれば解脱に達します
まとめて答えたことになったっけ
大丈夫です はい えーと
5時半ですけど どうしましょう
あの まだ質問はありますけど
また後日  なんかどうしても答えなくちゃいけないような質問もある
そうですね  うーん 早く答え
パッパッパッパと答えることもできますけど
うん じゃあいくつか へいへいさんでしたですね
私は給料の一部を慈善団体に布施しております
ですが もっと金があればもっと善行為ができるのに
誰か助けられるのにと怒りが生まれてしまいます
正しい心で布施をするにはどうすれば良いでしょうか？というんです
うーん あのね 一人の人間にはね
全ての人間を幸福にすることはできません
これは布施すると自分の心が清らかになって人格が向上する
それしか得られないんです
私は一人の人にご飯をあげたからといって
その人の問題は解決しません
その人は明日もお腹が空くんです
ある病気の人に治療代をあげて
お医者さんに見せて治してあげるのは素晴らしいことですけど
それでその人の問題は消えたわけじゃないんです
その人は再び病気になるんです
だから 何団体 慈善  慈善
慈善団体などは人のドネーションによって成り立ってますよ
赤十字軍もいろんな組織が社会を良くしようと頑張っているんだけど
もうだからといってそれが答えでもないし
それやめることも答えではないんです
そこは理解してほしいんです
だから 一人の人間が自分の力
ある範囲で他の生命を助ける
他の生命を本当に助けたければ
あなた修行して悟ってください
それで人は本気で助けることができます
だからそれを理解すれば
あなたが怒ることはなくなると思います
はい  はい 次ですね 次は野見さんという方ですかね
懺悔 懺悔についての質問です
日々懺悔した方が良いとのことですが
欲や怒りに基づく行為が悪行為だとすると
1 日のうち悪 行為は数え切れないほど大量にあることになります
それでは大量の悪行為がすべて懺悔の対象になるのでしょうか？それとも自分で懺悔する基準を決めてよいのでしょうか？という
これは面倒くさいんだから
私は言いたいのはもう懺悔することはもうもうもう癖にしてください
だって我々はどれぐらい悪いことするのかとわからないんだから
いくらなんでも たとえ阿羅漢になったっても
やったことは他人に迷惑になったっていうことはあり得るんです
だから阿羅漢以外はもうハチャメチャ懺悔しなくちゃいけないんですよ
だからもういつでもある
日本文化であるでしょ
いつでもごめん すいません
あれとかね 口癖でしょ
あれってちょっと真剣に
いつでも朝も懺悔する
夜布団に入ったら 一日はもういろんな間違い事を起こしましたから懺悔しますとかね
というふうにもう懺悔することはもう毎日の癖になるように慣れる
慣れた方がいいと思います
他はもうあまり考えない方がいいんです
人に間違いを起こさず生活することはもう成り立たないんです
だからと言って間違いを犯していいわけでもないんです
どうしますかね 間違いを犯してはならんよ
しかし 人間なら間違いを犯す
どうする？懺悔するしかないんです
はい では最後にお坊さん二人揃っているので
短い祝福経典で終了いたします
えーと どんな経典にしましょうかね
ナモータッサーバガトアーラトサンマサンブッダッサーナモータッサーバガトアーラトサンマサンブッダッサーナモータッサーバガトアーラトサンマサンブッダッサー
イティピソーバガヴァラーンサンマサンブッドーヴィンヤーチャーナサンパンノスガトーローカイトーアヌッタラ―
purisaダンマサーリプッタサンターデーヴァマヌッサーナンブッドーバガワーティーサーカートーバーガターダンモーサンブリッティコーアカーリコーエーティ
パッシコーコーパナイコーパッチャッタンエーディタンボーヴィンニューイーティーシュパティパンノーバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴージパティパンノーバガヴァトー
サーヴァカサンゴーニャーヤパティパンノーバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴーサーミージバティパンノーバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴーヤディダンチャッターリ
purisaユガーニアッタpurisaブングラーウェーサバガヴァトーサーヴァカサンゴー
パウネーヨパウネーヨダッキネーヨアンジャリカラニーヨアヌッタランプンニャーケッタムローカサーティーエーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナパートゥタングラタナ
ッタヤンエーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナパートゥタングラタナッタヤンエーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナパートゥタングラタナッタヤンヤンキンチヴィッタングイ
デヴァーウラングワーサンゲーシュワーヤンラタナンパニータンナノーサマンアッティタカーラテーナーイダンピブッンドーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチェー
ナスワーッティヨートゥーカヤンヴィラーガンアマタムパニータムヤダッジャガーサッキャムニーサマヒトーナテーナダンメーナサマッティキンチイダンピダンメーラタ
ナンパニータンエーテーナサッチェーナスワーッティヨートゥーキーナンプーラナンナワンナッティサンガワンヴィラッタシッターヤーヤティケーバヴァスミンテーキー
ナヴィーヤーヴィルッリッチャンダーニッバンティテーラーヤターヤンパディーポーイダンピサンゲーラタナンパニータンエーテーナサッチェーナスワーッティヨートゥ
ーエーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナドゥッカールーパサミントゥテーエーテーナサッチャヴァッジェーナバーヤールーパサミントゥテーエーテーナサッチャヴァッジ
ェーナローガールーパサミントゥテーカラニーヤマッタクサレーナヤンタムサンタンパタンアビサミッチャダンコージュチャスージュチャスワチョーチャッサムドゥー
アナティマニーサントゥッサコーチャスガローチャアプラピッチョーチャハッランカドゥッティサンティンディリオチャニパコーチャアプラダンボークレースーアナヌゲ
トーナチャクンダンサマチャレーティンチエーナヴィンニューパレーンパワデーヨシュキノーワケーミノホントゥサンビサッタヴァントゥキタッターエーケージバナブー
タッティタサーヴァーターヴァラーヴァーナセサディーガヴァーイエーマンターヴァーマッジマーラッサカーヌカトゥーラディッターヴァーイエーヴァー
..
.ターレ チドゥーレー アサンティ アウィドゥーレー ブータワ サンバヴェーシーヴァー サンヴェサッタ̄ バヴァントゥ
スキタンターナ パロー パランニ クンベタナティ マンニエタ カッタ チナンカンチー ビャーローサナパティガ
サンニャーナーニャ マンニャッサ ドゥッカミッチェイヤ マーター タリヤム プッタン アユサエーカ プッタマヌラックチ
ェ ワンピ サッバ ブーテースー マナサンバーヴァーヤ アパリマーナッ メッタンジャ サンバロー カスミン マナサンバーヴァー
ヤー アパリマーナッ ウッダンナドーチャ ティリヤンチャ アサンバーダンナ ヴェーラン アサパッタン ティッタンチャラン
ニティンノーワー サヤーノーワー ヤーワタッサ ウィガタミンドー エタン サティン アディッテーヤ ブラーマメタン
ヴィーワラン イダ マーウデッテンチャ アヌパガッマ シーラワー ダッサネーナ サンパンノーカーメー スウィ
ネッヤ ゲーダン マンジャートゥ ラブドゥディヤン プナヴェーティーティ エテーナ サッチャ ワッジェーナ ソッティテー
ホーチュ サッマダー エテーナ サッチャ ワッジェーナ パートゥ トワン ラタナッタヤ エテーナ サッチャ ワッジェーナ
ホーチュ テジャイ マンガラン サンビティーヨ イワッジャントゥ サンバローゴ ヴィナッサトゥ マーテー バワッ
トゥ アンタラーヨ スキーディ カユコー バワ バワトゥ サッバ マンガラン ラッカントゥ サッバ デワター サッバ
ブンダーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティ バヴァントゥ テ バワトゥ サッバ マンガラン ラッカントゥ
サッバ デワター サッバ ダンマーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティ バヴァントゥ テ バワトゥ サッバ マンガラ
ン ラッカントゥ サッバ デワター サッバ サンガーヌバーヴェーナ サダー ソッティ バヴァントゥ テ アッカート
ゥ アッカ ブーターナン パーパッガー ニバーナ パリッタッサーヌバーヴェーナ アントゥティ サンムッパントゥディ
アーカーサッター チブッマッター デーヴァーナーガー マヒッディカ プンニャンタン アヌモーディットゥワ チラン ラッカントゥ ローカサーサナム
アーカーサッター チブッマッター デーヴァーナーガー マヒッディカ プンニャンタン アヌモーディットゥワ チラ
ン ラッカントゥ デーサナン アーカーサッター チブッマッター デーヴァーナーガー マヒッディカ
プンニャンタン アヌモーディットゥワ チラン ラッカントゥ トワン サダー
デーヴォ アッサトゥ カーレーナ サッサ サンパッティ ホーチュ チェ ピッタ バワトゥ ローコー チェ ラージャー バワトゥ ダンミコー
サードゥ サードゥ サードゥ
では あの お布施とかやりますかね
で 回向文で終了しますけど
はい 夜のあのお坊さんに
では皆様で回向の文を唱えてください
ちょっと安田さんも一緒に唱えてください
回向の文 法僧の三宝に来拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー瞑想によって積まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この句の句によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福でありますますように
そして解脱が得られますように
イミナー プンニャ カンベナ マノー バラ サマーガモ サタン サマーガモ ホーティ ヤーワ ニッバーナ パッティヤ
イミナー ワンデナ マーナナ プージャ パティパッティヤ アヌバーヴェーナ サッバ ドゥッカ ヴィナッサントゥ アサワッアクヤーワ ハング ホートゥ
サードゥサードゥサードゥ
では皆様ありがとうございます
お釈迦様の幸福が皆様に祝福がありますように
ありがとうございます
これでウェーサーカシッティ法要が終了いたします
ありがとうございました
カンティー パラマン タポー ティティッカ ニッバーナナン パラマン ワダンティー ブッダ